hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the expanding role of next
generation
dna sequencing in pji
diagnosis and clinical microbiology
part two i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
microgen diagnostics to learn more
visit them at microgendx
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that support tab found at
the top
right presentation window or report your
problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's
speakers first dr javid
pervazi james edward professor of
orthopedic surgery at sydney camal
medical college and thomas jefferson
university director
of clinical research at rothman
institute
and thomas jefferson university hospital
and dr james snyder professor of
pathology
and laboratory medicine at the
university of lewisville
and medical director of the clinical
microbiology of molecular
diagnostics laboratory at the university
of lewisville
hospital for a complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen gentlemen
welcome
dr bervisin you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much susie and thank you
to microgndx for providing this
educational podium and opportunity
and so what i will do over the next 20
minutes or so give you
some synopsis of all the research that
has gone on
at the rathbun institute related to the
use of next generation sequencing
for diagnosis of periprosthetic joint
infection
so as we all know a prosthetic joint
infection or pgi is a devastating
complication
that increases morbidity and results
mortality
the mortality from this condition is
parallel to that of many common cancers
this is a study we published recently on
medicaid patient population and if you
look at the survivorship survivorship
after developing an infection in the
total knee
has a five-year survivorship of 72
that's very similar to breast and
prostate cancer
and if you actually look at the
survivorship on this
instagram you will see that pji
is truly a deadly condition
the incident and the rate and economic
burden of infection continues to
increase
these are some projection studies that
i've done with steve kurtz
and we use the nis database
uh national inpatient sampling database
and if you look uh back in 2009 we
predicted that in 2013 there would be 30
000 infections and it looks like we had
underestimated the burden of infection
even though
it appears that it all uh is an
exponential uh
increase and the cost of the
increasing of treating a peripheral
joint infection
currently stands around 2 billion
dollars in united states alone
the question you may ask is why next
generation sequencing why would you be
interested in such a molecular
diagnostics
well first is that diagnosis of pji
continues to pose a challenge for us
in particular pji or any type of implant
related infections exist in the form of
a biofilm
where organisms gather together and
they're
they're covered by an umbrella of
glycocalyx
and the the glycocalyx is impenetrable
to immune
host cells such as neutrophils
and is also impenetrable to antibiotics
so this results in biofilm persisting
for a long time and seeding itself and
to be able to detect the
bacteria we rely on planktonic bacteria
floating around
if they exist in a sessile form of
biofilm
that happens to be very difficult the
second
and this is mostly based on the good
work of my friend
eddie shorts from university of
rochester it shows that
in the bottom slide here electron
microscopy
that staphorias usually invade the
canaliculi
in the inside the bone they continue to
grow
and they will kill those
cells the multi-nucleated cells that you
see over here the neutrophils
and result in complete invasion
of the bone resulting in osteomyelitis
so to be able to diagnose infection such
as osteomyelitis it's somewhat difficult
to isolate the infective organism
because they reside in these crevices
of bone and the other thing i want to
show you is this blue cell over here
the blue cells and osteoblasts and the
blue is a cytoplasm
the round body is actually staphorious
that's internalized itself inside
the osteoblast again not being
detectable
by the immune system we have seen
intracellular
particles intracellular pathogens
staphorius is a classical for doing that
and here is a very interesting study
that was published
what they call what they did they
co-cultured staff four years together
with
osteoblasts and then they washed away
the
uh staphorias transferred the
osteoblasts to the fracture model here
this is a rat fracture
femur and then what they found is that
after a period of time all of the
fractures got infected
even though there was no osteoplast no
no staphorius in those
transmitted medium it was the
staphorius that had internalized itself
inside the osteoblasts that were then
capable of in
infecting the rat femur
the american academy of orthopedic
surgeons has done
great work in producing this document i
was a co-chair of the committee that
worked on this these are guidelines
that provides the algorithm for
diagnosis of pji
and basically it relies on a series of
tests serology followed by aspiration
followed by analysis of the aspiration
fluid etc
international consensus meeting which we
also held back in philadelphia in 2018
has a massive document that actually
shows what exactly is going on with
regard to
some of the uh infection related issues
in particular diagnosis
the recommendations is if you suspect
infection in a patient the first thing
you would do
is you would order esr and crp a
serological test
that's the first line of screening if
these tests
are uh positive abnormal
or the test is uh uh
normal but you just your index of
suspicion is really high for an
infection
you would then go ahead and aspirate the
joint
and aspiration would then be would be
sent for neutral full differential the
neutrophil
count culture and possibly uh biomarkers
in 2018 we introduced a
new definition of periprosthetic joint
infection which is
evidence-based relies on pre-test
probability in a stepwise approach
and it actually assigns a score to each
one of these tests
so the minor criteria that we had
previously each of them and now
are assigned the score if the score is
above six
the patient is definitely infected if
the score is under
three the patient is definitely not
infected if the score is
four and five then it means you have to
do another diagnostic
series of diagnostic tests so
diagnosis of pgi continues to be
challenged we've seen up to about
50 percent of paraprosthetic joint
infections culture being negative
and when the culture is negative it
carries a
huge issue for the patient and the
health care providers
first the patient is being told that
they have to undergo multiple operations
without knowing what organism caused
their infection
and healthcare providers infectious
these doctors
don't really know which antibiotics to
use because the pathogen
of target is unknown so because of that
the outcome of culture negative
infections it's somewhat
suboptimal it is not surprising
why culture fails in some of these
circumstances
culture is an 1886 technology it's
imperfect
it relies on a huge number of factors to
come together
it is complicated you've got to take
culture from the right spot
you have to then send it to the lab at
the right time
and you have to be able to also put it
in the right medium
to be able to then uh isolate the
infected organism
and it's because of that the infectious
disease society of north america
recommended that culture samples should
be transferred to the lab within one
hour
for a processing and incubation
the impact of traditional culture is
unknown currently
we are not quite sure why culture is
negative in some of these cases
and the uh culture system
again with the implant relate to can be
negative in a very large number of
patients as we just discussed so what
can you do
well you could rely on molecular
techniques one of them is pcr
for diagnosis pgi that was actually
described at jefferson
and the 1996 paper was by dr rocky twan
and this was utilizing a single species
pcr to try to detect
organisms in the synovial fluid and then
came the broad range pcr that was also
published later
and we were also interested in multiplex
pcr in the 2012 paper that we published
utilize multiplex pcr for isolation of
the organisms
uh in the synovial fluid
but there are limitations to pcr first
of all pcr
you need to know what organism you're
looking for so you can then design
your primer targeted towards that
organism
second pcr will amplify and detect
uh non-viable dna as well as uh
real pathogens and then the other issue
with pcr is that somewhat time consuming
and it's extremely sensitive
ngs on the other hand is the
sequencing of the dna fragments of a
given sample
and you don't really need a primer to be
able to sequence these and once the
sequencing is done
then you run that against phylogeny of
bacteria
and other pathogens and it will
tell you which organisms exist in that
given tissue
the american society for microbiology in
american academy of microbiology
produces very valuable document that
basically summarizes their findings
and they feel there's a huge potential
for next-generation sequencing
because it will revolutionize the
clinical microbiology lab
by replacing the time consuming and
labor intensive technique
with a single and all-inclusive
diagnostic test
are there examples of ngs being used in
clinical arena
absolutely numerous articles and i will
highlight some of them and i will
highlight some of the work that we have
done
this is a 14 year old boy that was
admitted
hospital in wisconsin with severe
sepsis and all tests including serology
brain biopsy csf etc
all of them failed to isolate the
infected organism
and when this was actually sent to
next-generation sequencing
leptospirosis was isolated
high dose of penicillin patient was then
sent home a week or ten days later
so absolutely invaluable and part of
reason why ngs has gained huge attention
in recent years
is because of a rapid decline in the
cost of sequencing
look at this nih slide it shows you what
has happened over time
with the decline rapid decline in the
cost of sequencing
it's so much so that human genome
project could be actually done
in a day at a cost of two hundred
dollars
so we have published a few papers uh
related to
the use of ngs for diagnose superior
prosthetic joint infection
we have seen uh cases like streptococcus
canis
being isolated from the synovial fluid
of a patient that had been
scratched by a dog previously
so very interesting direct transfer
trans
fur of pathogen from mouth of a pet
into the implant and then
the naturation sequencing being able to
isolate that particular
organism and there has been numerous
number of
other types of case reports been
being published that shows engine ngs
can
isolate some very atypical and some very
unusual organisms so how about
diagnostic data versus culture
we published another paper in the
journal bone and joint surgery back in
2018
we evaluated the utility of ngs for
pathogen detection
in particular cultural negatives we had
14 academic centers that contributed
cases to this all patients were
evaluated pre-operatively
and then the msis or the international
consensus
criteria was utilized to categorize them
as infected or not infected
the synovial fluid was aspirated prior
to arthrotomy deep tissue samples as
well as swabs percent
and this is what we usually do we send
all of those
to the laboratory and what we found and
here the videos do not play but
basically we now utilize a special swab
called
captive swab and again on the microgen
dx's website
there is a specific details on how to
sample these uh tissues and these swabs
are then transmitted to microgen dx
and then processed at microgen
so what we found here is that the first
report that comes out which is the level
1 assay on quants to the pcr
and then the second assay is the
detailed
sequencing of all the organisms and the
report
is uh is like this the first and then
the level two report comes back
and the level two report tells you which
organism is there
and what the percentage of uh
dna was in that particular sample it
also
gives you by projection uh
will give you some antibiotic
susceptibility
and professor snyder will be given the
next talk and he
clearly has so much more knowledge in
this field
and he will uh provide his insight
as to what to do with ngs with regard to
the sensitivity of the organisms
for treatment purposes so i know this
this is a slightly busy slide but
basically what this shows you
is that ngs was very good at detecting
pathogens when the culture was negative
ngs was occasionally positive in cases
that were not
infected which we believe is reflective
of the the resident
microbiome of that particular uh
body cavity but in all all in all
ngs isolated organisms when culture
failed
in infected cases in 90
of these patients
and if you look at this slide it's a bar
graph that shows a comparison between
ngs and culture and again ngs was
extremely valuable
in isolating organisms when culture
failed
so that based on that study we felt that
ngs holds great promise for detection of
pathogens in the
in the context of culture negative pgi
and then that was the reason for a
collaborative multi-center study which i
will
share the results of but interestingly
what we have come to
realize is that majority of pgi are
caused by poly microbial organisms
and culture only isolates the most
dominant organism and misses the others
that are there for the right the next
question is
is the signal relevant for treatment
failure
so this was our hypothesis that the
failure after surgical management of pji
occurs as a result of organisms that
were there in the first place
and persisted throughout the antibiotic
treatment
and then they become resistant or the
antibiotic pressure pushes them
to become professional pathogens as bill
costa would put it
and then result in a later failure
this is the result of a prospective
study that's really spent over two and a
half years
and we have had 14 academic centers
and all patients were evaluated
preoperatively
and then categorized as infected versus
non-infected
we were interested in treatment failure
that being defined
by the delphi criteria as any
re-operation for infection
or of course failure and
for removal of the prosthesis amputation
or arthrodesis these included all
revision cases there were 214 infected
563 uninfected 139 of these patients
failed later by reoperation and the
organism was confirmed on culture
in 67 and a half percent of these failed
cases the organism at
failure was present on the ngs
at the first surgical procedure
again this was observational study we
obviously did not do any
intervention based on the ngs data but
interestingly the ngs data was very
relevant here because
in a two-thirds of the cases when later
failure occurred
the failure was a result of an organism
that had been there from day one
so this is another interesting area
where you can see that revision
for the patients undergoing revision
either as a result of infection
or accepting etiology and ngs being very
very
useful in isolating the organisms
particularly from the infected cases
that were culture negative
so there is a strong relationship
between ngs signal
revision and subsequent failure based on
this data
and further follow-up now we have come
to
make a recommendation that at the time
of
infection treatment by surgery when
resection arthroplasty or similar type
of procedures being performed
ngs signal is critical and any organism
isolated by ngs should be treated
otherwise they will come back and result
in a later failure
the multi-center studies also provided
very
valuable information to us regarding
joint microbiome
every joint in the body potentially has
organisms that live in our body in
symbiotic
uh situation much like elsewhere
shoulder for example is shown to have a
distinct microbiome signal
the breast cancer tissues
that were collected in this particular
nature paper also had a microbiome
that related to organisms existing in
symbiotic
fashion and so what we wanted to do was
to take
samples from hip and knee patients who
are undergoing
uh replacement these are the patients
that are having the first surgery
they have never been operated on they
just have osteoarthritis
then we would send these for various
analyses by next generation sequencing
and the heat wave map here which i know
is very very complicated
shows that numerous types of organisms
existed in both hip
and the knee cases and a very distinct
microbiome was present
in these patients and if you look at the
overlap in the composition between the
hips and the knees
there was quite a bit of an overlap so
the microbiome in the large
weight-bearing joints appear to be
pretty similar
and then the other question that we had
asked and we have done some work on is
which organism predicts pgi
and the organisms that are relevant
for failure or the pathogens well-known
pathogens were of a special interest for
us
and what we wanted to do was identify
species detected by ngs
that may predict pgi and build a
predictive model pgi
in a developmental cohort and then
validate the predictive utility of the
model
in a separate multi-institutional
study and here we did analyses of
composition of microbiomes
and we had 17 bacterial candidates
regression analysis etc which i will not
bore you with the details
and what we found was that the model
was optimal when tested for the
microbiome
and this model was actually very
interesting in terms of showing us
the distribution of various organisms in
these joints
and as you can see from these violin
graphs
the microbiome of the hip
and the knee was very very distinct
and very similar in nature so this model
had an overall predictive
value of about 75.9 and this was based
on distribution of thousand
predictive model iterations which again
i will not bore you with the details
uh and you can certainly access those
on the microsoft dx website so
in conclusion what we have found is that
pgi is a devastating complication of
total joint arthroplasty
culture is an imperfect technology
that's too often inadequate in
identifying a pathogen
and in this multi-chord study what we
found was ngs was effective in
identifying pathogen and pgi
particularly culture negative cases
the signal found by ngs is predictive of
organisms causing later
reinfection and a clinically relevant
and highly accurate predictive model has
been built
using the microbial dna signal
identified by ngs
and i believe this will be very useful
moving forward
i want to thank all of these
institutions including professor
snyder's institution university of
louisville
and others that contribute to these
studies
and have certainly increased our
insight and awareness of how challenging
pgi
is and what a great value ngs has
in helping us manage these patients
thank you very much
for your uh for your time now what i
would like to do is
uh i would like to have uh to introduce
professor james snyder
professor snyder is a professor of
microbiology and pathology from
university of louisville
i've had the honor of knowing him from
distance i haven't had the opportunity
to actually work with him closely
but we have obviously collaborated
worked on numerous projects
and as i mentioned professor snyder's
institution provided
samples for the multi-core study that we
have presented
but he's been a real thought leader in
this field
he thinks outside the box he's been able
to see the utility of
ngs and molecular techniques to address
some of the shortcomings of
of culture and he has had an incredibly
insightful
guidance on some of these studies that
we've done so far
and i look forward to working with him
closely and i
more importantly look forward to
listening to him tonight
to give us this lecture thank you very
much professor snyder
thank you dr parvisi for that very
interesting uh
discussion and for the introduction
i'd like to thank uh lab roots
and of course our sponsor microgendx for
making this possible
i have one disclosure to share with you
they have guests at the advisory board
held by
microgen dx
these are the objectives that i tend to
cover in the next
few minutes regarding the value of
ngs our real life experience
if you will in adding ngs to our test
service or menu
show you some representative patient
cases
and finish off with some current issues
that we're dealing with
and also some future applications that
we
are associated with
dr parvija gave you a very good overview
of what ngs
is i won't go into great detail i'm also
assuming that many of you
are probably more familiar than gs than
i am
but we will refer to in the testing
process
at uh microgen dx
level one level two there's also a level
three that i will mention
at the appropriate time but it begins
with quantitative pcr
uh followed by next generation
sequencing
and once i show you the reports i think
you'll have a better understanding
of the information that we are getting
within a very uh
practical period of time
the reports that i'll show you and this
relates to the quantitative pcr
there's actually three designations that
you may see on the report
one is low medium and high
and this refers to the
cut off values or thresholds relating to
the
amount of dna copies per ml so
low is a value of less than
10 to the fifth medium is 10 to the
fifth 10 to the seventh
and high is greater than 10 to the 7th
so white ngs and i put
a little comment there who is there
simply indicating that when we go into
ngs we're asking what is in there
and i have to give credit to dr
michael schmidt current professor of
microbiology and immunology to medical
university of south carolina
who participated in part one so he keyed
this statement who is there it caught me
as
a very practical but yet very
representative
uh aspect of what ngs is
i firmly believe that ngs is a the
future of clinical microbiology
uh ngs has been around for a while but
slowly adopted
and becoming part of the clinical
microbiology
area uh one word for me would summarize
it
it's called survival and as microbiology
progresses and
ngs is going to play a big role
several values or benefits of ngs
it's independent of organism viability
and of course culture it detects
bacteria fungi viruses
parasites in one assay some metagemic if
you will
so we're seeing targeting of sequences
of multiple targets
in a single organism it also sequences
and identifies
multiple organisms in a single specimen
and some of our patient reports uh you
you will appreciate that
uh it detects non-culturable or
fastidious organisms that are often
missing culture
and i have to bring up a couple terms
that you may or may not be familiar with
one of which is viable but
non-culturable
organisms these organisms are viable but
because of environmental stress placed
upon them
they will not be recovered in culture
but they're still virulent
and they're capable of causing disease
usually the end product or the
consequence of this
is chronic type of infections or
symptoms
with seemingly no known cause another
group are what we call
persisters they are tolerant to
antibiotics
but refractory to treatment so as a
result of that
culture will miss those and as a result
of that
specimens also
and i think everyone will agree with
this when you get a specimen in
from surgery it's pan culture
mycomycology
mycobacteriology bacteriology
and possibly a molecular assay
that requires a lot of media and
and labor and as a result of that it's
costly
the cost of ngs is coming down
significantly and the limited
comparisons i've done with costs
yes ngs is a little more expensive but
not significantly more expensive
than the pan culturing that is common
with many of these specimens that come
in
so it's a reasonable cost and once again
the results
have been available and continue to be
available
in less than 96 hours some organisms
require up to 96 hours to grow i.e
cardio bacterium is one of those we hold
ours for 11 days
before we call them negative next gen
will detect them in less than 96 hours
and that level one they may be detected
in a quantitative
pcr and i've given you a reference there
at the bottom that gives you a nice
overview
of ngs
so what has been our experience in
adding ngs to the test menu
well it started with an orthopedic
surgeon coming to me and he says have
you thought about
providing ngs2 to our service
and obviously the answer was no and i
said
i would look into it and i met with the
representative
from microgen dx and we discussed it
learned more about it and i went to
another orthopedic surgeon and i need to
clarify
we support because we're a core
laboratory
two orthopedic groups
uh one deals with arthroplasty
and revisions the other deals with
trauma
i.e fractures so meeting with the
orthopedic surgeon that's associated
with trauma
and our institution where the core
laboratory is located is primarily a
trauma center
and we discussed it and he suggested why
don't we do a pilot study
and determine get some experience
and determine if we should pursue this
even further
and we agreed to do that so we
contacted the company and they agreed to
support
a pilot study of approximately 20
patients
at no charge and then they provided us
we had to learn and we're still on a
learning curve because we've been doing
this now for
just a little over two years and
microgen diagnostic
provided us with the collection
guidelines
which include four swabs joint fluid
or pus and tissue in addition to the
specimen
and shipping containers and the goal was
to compare it with
conventional culture and to determine
the
level of concordance between culture and
ngs
you know we also have to consider
administrative logistics
if we go with this what's going to be
the charge to the laboratory
we have to establish a contract who is
responsible for the shipping containers
to use fedex
how are we going to get the reports who
gets the reports
and then one of my key factors was
i want to see their their validation
data
i want to know if they're licensed by
clia are they cap accredited how are
they doing in their proficiency testing
i won't go into the charges to the
laboratory because that's going to be a
result
or be influenced by your volume and etc
we did establish a contract
they provide the fedex shipping
costs in addition to the collection
containers and so forth
and i would recommend that you go on
youtube
video and pull up microgen dx they have
a very good and recent
specimen collection video and dr pravigi
alluded to the well i consider an
innovative swab
for collecting specimens
i have never been a proponent of swabs
for a variety of reasons but i think
this new swab that's in that video
that dr parvisi alluded to uh
i'm getting confidence with it the other
the other aspect was the receipt of
reports and
our physicians are given a code
uh by the company where they can get in
to
their reports and evaluate them as soon
as they become
available i also get copies of the
report
keep files on both groups of each
patient that was seen by those
respective orthopedic groups
and after looking at their validation
data i found it acceptable
and uh once again this is just a summary
of their
um proficiency testing with cap
they are clear licensed and uh
my level of comfort with that was very
very good
so show you some representative patient
cases i can't show you the official
report
with this but you see three columns
there culture results
quantitative pcr results and next
generation
sequencing results in patient one we saw
in culture one colony of staph aureus
the quantitative pcr results
detected the staph aureus and also
enterococcus
fesium and once again as i mentioned
earlier
the low means there was less than 10 to
the fifth
well the ngs detected the predominance
of staphylococcus aureus
no ephesium which is not surprising to
me
the next patient as you can see in
culture had
one plus pseudomonas virginosa one plus
mrsa
those two organisms were found in
multiple cultures
and in one additional culture from the
left hip there was no growth in 48 hours
quantitative pcr once again none
detected
not surprising given the small quantity
of organisms that were recovered in
culture but the ngs results picked up
the pseudomonas virginosa
the staph hemolyticus and once again
the ephesium was the predominant one
percentage-wise
so ephesian was 73 pseudomonas following
and staphylococcus
hemolyticus so i also
became very very uh comfortable with the
fact that most of these infections
are polymicrobial in nature so many
times you'll get
maybe one or two organisms in culture
and many more as i'll show you later
with ngs so here's another patient there
was no growth at 48 hours
quantitative pcr sitting undetected
ngs results looked at the number of
organisms that were detected
led by staph aureus
we also are learning new organisms and i
call your attention to the bottom
of the uh first uh slide there the
case three the patent of phyllis
rhinitis had no idea what that was
and usually when we have organisms like
that and report it we get a phone call
what is this
well this organism is formerly privately
disions
which you can see with seven percent of
the population
generated by ngs and this organism is an
anaerobe
anaerobic oxide but once again has been
reclassified picked up by ngs
case four at four plus staph aureus uh
a lot of organisms there but none
detected we've got a result of medium
and once again the staph aureus was 100
uh found in the ngs results
one other patient here you can see at
group c strep streporalis and undetected
in qc
uh acute pcr but look at the
number of organisms or genes that
protected in the ngs
with 37 percent being a streptococcus
species
that probably was a group c strap or it
could have been the strep orals
but once again we saw strep aroused 17
in addition to the other organisms
listed there
this is a formal report this is level
two
and as you can see here a variety of
organisms
and some of which once again is our
friend pepnophilius
and once again in the percentage of
predominance
with sapphires leading the way and then
the third phase
is what they call the resistome
and where you see the check marks that
indicates these organisms
are most likely to respond to those
therapies
which is based primarily on current
literature findings
regarding the organism versus the
respective antibiotic
so for each organism there is a
prediction
if you will of the likelihood
it's been shown that this antibiotic has
activity against that organism
this was an hiv patient that we had the
cultures were all negative we did
recover mycobacterium avian complex this
is a left ankle
uh specimen tissue but one of the
organisms that is common
or morally associated with the
hiv patients is mycobacterium homophilum
we did not recover that culture we did
set up a chocolate plate
in addition to our regular mycobacterium
media
but once again the avion was detected
in culture but the mycobacterium
hemophilus
was negative but it did
appear in the next generation sequencing
and we really was the predominant
organism
so in our pilot study to refer back to
the previous slide
we showed a 73 concordance
between culture and next generation
sequencing
and obviously additional organisms were
recovered
or detected rather with ngs
i wanted to show you this slide on a
report once again level two the
respective organisms but you'll notice
in the far
column the the under the antibiotics the
amino glycosides and so forth
those uh areas are shaded well if you
look at the up
above the level two area they
indicate which antibiotics those
respective organisms are resistant to
they actually list them
but on your report you will see that
plus you will see the shaded area
that i referred to when i brought this
slide up
we have also taken the next step and we
send
non-sporulating molds or sterile molds
for next generation sequencing and
here are four representatives of uh
fungi that i've never heard of
but have allowed me to learn and
understand their
clinical relationship where they're at
commonly they're all environmental
organisms the only organism of this
group that i
have had experience with is the
acetospheria
restrado which is formerly the x-zero
hyland stratum
that we recovered from a breast tissue
so it's very hard to really determine
their clinical relevance
because in many of these cases they fail
to get histological examinations
and send tissue for that purpose and we
we try to encourage and influence the
clinicians if you're going to order
culture on tissue
please order histopathology because if
you can demonstrate the organism
in the tissue there's a good chance that
that organism is clinically relevant
so of the four here i could not
determine
nor could the infectious disease people
determine if these other organisms were
contaminants
or just collected or obtained during
collection
so what is the current status of the
future applications of next generation
sequencing
well one of the problems we have
encountered is the fact
that there's been a lot of inconsistency
with collecting the recommended
number of specimens that is a part of
this ngs program
the specimens that should be collected
are four swabs
tissue and fluid if available
and that's been a problem with the
specimens at least that we received
and the lack of consistency in getting
all those specimens at one time
i know from talking with our
counterparts of microgen dx
the preferred specimens for their work
are the four swabs uh with the tissue
and the fluid can be retained by the
laboratory
uh for for culture but once again that's
something you have to work out
with your providers regarding uh
do we culture them all or do we just
send four swabs and
those are some of the details we're
working out with our respective
providers
the logistics related to responsible
party for shipment of specimens
because we are a core laboratory that
one orthopedic group
is in another facility we've resolved
that
satellite laboratory if you will is
responsible for sending those specimens
for next gen sequencing so to this point
we're satisfied with the service which
includes turnaround time
their responsiveness and the reasonable
cost that they charge per specimen
and the physicians are seem to be very
satisfied
and i like to interact with physicians i
believe microbiologists or directors
need to get out of their silos and
interact with the medical
staff let them know who we are what we
do that also includes the nurses
it's very valuable for identifying
sterile or unidentifiable molds
and the sooner you get the answer the
better it is
hopefully for the patient if it's a
contaminant fine but at least we know
what it is
we are sending bals
that have been in patients with no
detectable infectious agent
patient is still very ill so we'll take
the bal
we'll send it the next gen and we
usually are very successful
in coming up with a pathogen this even
applies to positive or
blood cultures that are negative when
you know that through the gram stain
there's something there
uh the morphology and we've sent a
couple blood cultures down
for next-gen sequencing and have come
back positive
for the organism that we could not
recover in culture
so for me interacting with orthopedic
surgeons has been a very uh
fun activity we get rare and new
organisms
clinical relevance is the big question
and
at least in our learning curve i get
that question
quite a bit from the orthopedic surgeons
and my comment is because i don't know
i'm not a practicing physician i say
what does your patient look like
i think with the addition of the
resistance
phase for the susceptibility or the
predictability of
response to those antibiotics that helps
them in terms of
clinical relevance but they make the
final clinical decisions
so but i think the clinical
microbiologist without a doubt has to be
involved
from day one not only from the
implementation
considering both the technical as well
as administrative aspect
but be available to discuss through
uh result interpretation uh
what these organisms are what they've
been associated with
and when we get a rare or unusual
organism we've never heard of
uh we will do a literature search and
and and pick out a couple recent papers
and on the report we will put the the
journal
title the volume the year we
and we don't send the paper but they
have the reference that they want to
read about it
and then of course fungal id uh has
already proven itself
uh we are getting ready to uh
use next gen for cystic fibrosis
patients which is
a biofilm in itself and several
organisms in there
that we know we're not culturing but
they're there so
that has yet to start but it soon will
be online after the first
year and then some of the eent
physicians around town are beginning to
call and we have
uh started with one eent group and as a
result of that
it's too early to tell but very
interested in that
so by way of summary for microbiology
ngs is in its infancy as far as the
laboratory is concerned
uh so we outsource it right now
hopefully someday we can bring in
nextgen into our laboratory uh
and work with our hematopathologists uh
once again we're in an era of rapid
diagnostics
traditional culture is still the gold
standard but you know as well as i do
that days uh are are not uncommon in
getting positive results
but rapid diagnostics is the error that
we're in and will continue to be
once again we're dealing with a
situation at least in the orthopedic
world
poly microbial infections we have to
deal with that
and i mentioned the viable but
non-conservable organisms
the optimal utilization of ngs that's
been a question asked of mike
from my colleagues is there an optimal
way to use
ngs rather than do it on every situation
i think it depends upon
the clinicians you're working with but i
would definitely
recommend it if it's been culture
negative do ngs
and whether or not you pair with culture
i think is a question that you have to
work out with your colleagues
outcome studies are critically needed i
know dr parvisi is doing some of those
and what we really need are outcome
studies to show
the impact and the positive impact that
it has
on on patient satisfaction because as
you know we're in an
era of a new reimbursement format
where we are also looking at the
uh the value-based reimbursement
and uh that's beginning to be
the way that providers are paid and once
again we i think that
next gen sequencing will be
an asset to that will it replace culture
or adjuncts to the culture
i don't think of a replace culture that
i think currently
is an adjunct but once again the future
is it's nice to look into so the answer
that question
is in your own domain i say it will not
it will be a supplement but once again
only time will tell
but once again it really is an
opportunity for the clinical
microbiologist to interact with the
provider
and with that i will thank you
and thank you doctor and dr schneider
that informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar and i do want to encourage
our audience members to click on that
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we have time for just a couple of
questions however any questions
not answered at this time will be
answered via email
by our presenters so let's take a look
at our
questions coming in already our first
question is
what is the clinical relevance of
genomic
data in the absence of phenotypic
information
when the culture is negative and the
absence of
anti-microbial susceptibility data
to guide the provider in selecting
appropriate empiric
or targeted therapy
dr steiner would you like to answer that
one or should i
uh say i think that's the clinical
question
that's the question i get from some of
our users
primarily infectious disease personnel
so
how do you know what the clinical
relevance is that all you're dealing
with
is a genomic based result
and you heard me say earlier that i
always ask the clinician
what does your patient look like
so how do you handle the
data when you know it's genomic without
any
susceptibility results that have been
generated
from the laboratory knowing that the
results
or the activities are predicted on what
we have from the literature
which is being used by uh dx
thank you so much dr snyder and dr
parvici did you want to add
yeah i think that that's very insightful
response
i completely agree with dr snyder in
that when you are
faced with data uh from various tests
you must always put them into a clinical
context
to try to make sense of the data and see
if that actually
makes sense so if you've got a patient
that has
a rip-roaring infection and culture has
been negative by next-generation
sequencing gives you
a list of four or five organisms
i would assume in that case that they
are all real and i would treat all those
four
based on what we've discussed but if you
have a situation where you don't suspect
infection all the other parameters like
blood tests
sterology synovial fluid etc all of that
points towards a non-infection cause
and genomics may pick up one or two
organisms
then in that circumstance i would most
likely
sit and wait and not treat
those organisms as dr snyder said the
world of rapid diagnostics is evolving
we're learning more and more and as
further
evidence and science has generated we
will know more about what to do with the
genomics data
but for now i think genomics data is
very invaluable on some of these
patients who are infected and remain
culture negative
thank you so much i do want to make sure
i give you both time
to provide some final comments so i'll
give you one more question from our
audience
will the next generation sequencing
replace
traditional culture
well i think i've already answered that
my my position is no
i think it will is still a supplement
to next generation sequencing
dr pardesi i completely agree at this
juncture i think having ngs
alongside culture provides invaluable
data
what will happen to culture in the
future remains to be known but at this
point
to answer your audience's question is
that no it will not replace culture but
it will only supplement it
gentlemen thank you very much for your
presentation today dr pervizzi would you
like to provide the audience members
with any closing remarks
yeah so again once again i want to thank
you susie and dr snyder for sharing the
podium with me
i want to thank microgendx for providing
this educational activity
i want to tell people that we've been
very excited about
ngs three or four years ago when i
didn't have data i may not have been as
excited as i am today
and i think in the next few years we're
going to see ngs play more and more
critical role
in managing some of these very complex
patients
if you haven't tried dngs i strongly
urge you to reach out to microgen dx
ask them for kids try them on some
patients like dr snyder did in their
initial phase
and you will be very pleasantly
surprised
thank you so much dr parvizi and dr
schneider would you like to provide a
few words
the only thing i can add to what dr
parvizi summarized extremely well
is we're in an era of rapid
diagnostics we have the tools
and microbiology's future is dependent
on these tools
we have them available we need to start
using them
and we also have a responsibility
to contribute to cost-effective medicine
because of the new era reimbursable
activity that we're associated with
today so
i'm very excited about what i see down
the road with
ngs and i'm very happy to be a part
of the game today thank you
and thank you very much dr snyder dr
parvizi thank you both for your time
today and thank you for your important
research
and i also want to thank lab roots and
our sponsor microgen diagnostics for
underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go i want to thank the audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
remember that any questions
not having time for today and those
submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
stay
safe bye bye
thank you